I'm ready see I'm Batman this is
tomorrow saying this is not Batman but
I've seen Batman vs Superman I have not
so I have some questions for you but I'm
gonna keep this spoiler free for you and
for everyone at home so I'm gonna try
and answer them as best I can avoiding
big spoilers
although the trailer literally spoiled
yeah pretty much every major plot point
in that film so I think the best
starting point is general overview how
did you feel coming away from it were
you happy with what you saw were you
confused or were you like why why have
you done this to me Zack Snyder I'm not
I'm not right this is no weight of a lie
I genuinely lay awake for a really long
time last night just thinking about what
I've seen in a bad way oh no good no
that's the thing like I still can't make
up my mind about it because you gotta
commend Zack Snyder because he had a lot
of stuff to put in that you cannot fault
him for being ambitious because he that
is a really ambitious movie but the
thing is the plot I think as well the
film sword of suffers from deleted scene
itis in that like it jumps around a bit
and things are just introducing
characters are just introduced and
you're a bit like yeah what's going on
so it feels like it feels definitely
like there's some deleted scenes and I
think there already is gonna be like a
director's cut yeah Snyder loves this
direct it's an extra 30 minutes which
does seem to me like a lot of there has
been deleted that explains a lot some of
it right there when you're watching the
film there are genuine glimmers of hope
look this will be like the gritty dark
DC Titans coming together that we've all
wanted it's gonna be great but I think
and this is a weird analogy but you have
to hear me out it kind of suffers from
the same problems as Jupiter setting did
in that Jupiter ascending is a film
we're really stupid things happen but
all the cast of characters come at it
with like this really po-faced morality
based and and they try and make it
really serious whereas if they just have
fun with it it would have been a very
very different movie right and I think
that's very similar about my mr.
Superman in that it's really serious
and then stupid things happen
but everyone still is keeping radio a
series and just like everything is so
macho and so po-faced
that it's very difficult to take it like
as a viewer it's very difficult to sort
of like appreciate it right I guess a
lot of people would argue that the DC
Universe is a lot darker than the
alternative ones that our God and what
Warner and DC are trying to do is
present something different from Marvel
Marvel movies are light and quite fun
whereas and colorful whereas DC are
trying to corner the market on gritty
and grim does it achieve that or has it
gone a bit too dark with with Superman
or Batman so like the whole film like
the atmosphere is dark it's gritty it's
like a ruined metropolis it's the crime
filled Gotham it's very dark the way
that Batman and now Superman are both
these really dark characters like that
works but also there's just some weird
moments where like if they happen in any
other movie it would be a comedy right
okay like and I mean one of these
husbands fall in the trailer well I'm
not gonna spoil it here
it's the final third of the movie just
borders into absolutely ridiculous okay
you mentioned Gotham and metropolis I
think a lot of people what they're gonna
want to know is what's the balance
between Batman and Superman like because
obviously people go in there liking one
or like in the other you know not many
people go in there wanting both
characters but how how well does the
movie strike a balance between those two
characters and their alter egos Clark
and then Bruce I think like in terms of
screen time it's really even a split but
I also think it's incredibly clear that
Zack Snyder just wanted to make a Batman
movie okay which is why we see his
origin story again so you know if you
don't know how Batman star ends you will
know again so obviously Superman had Man
of Steel as his like origin story movie
reboot again
TenPoint is it to watch that movie watch
that movie I want you to forget it
that's yeah I mean like slog your way
through that but I think it is very key
because a lot of characters and plot
points from Man of Steel I do surface
the tornado comes back to kill the rest
of
of course Batman does get like the
better part of the story but you see
this Batman who's just like beleaguered
after years of fighting crime in Gotham
and he's really not impressed with the
way the Superman just sort of swoops in
and does what everyone but the thing is
the one big worldwide event that turns
everyone against Superman is quite
bizarre and you really have to pay
attention to because I was just watching
it I was like I thought it was just a
sort of Superman smooth feeling super
thing turns out that's like the big
moment there's a class of eggs in the
fridge instead of the cupboard okay
that's those two characters covered but
there's one more yeah obviously Wonder
Woman is a huge part of this she issued
a huge part of this or is she just in
there to be like hey we've got another
movie coming it's gonna have a bunch of
other superheroes in it this is our
connection to it or does she have an
important role in the movie and how well
is she kind of laid across something she
is a great character uh and so she
actually spends a lot of the movie not
in costume rule so it's her alter ego
she was great and I really enjoyed her I
and I am genuinely excited gal gadot did
a really great job
speaking of Justice League as well don't
worry the seeds are sown it's not
doesn't seem to be a post-credits
sequence but it's it's a slap bang in
the middle of movies okay it seems like
what a lot of people are saying is it's
kind of like a middling movie but it's
kind of held up by Ben Affleck as Batman
and Wonder Woman's appearance kind of
like a shallow film is that fair to say
I think showers unfair because they do
try and do a lot Ben Affleck is really
great I think I think when you do do
need to take some time out to say the
fan off like is a really great Batman
but a really great Bruce Wayne like I
wasn't really convinced our batfleck
when you first got cast but I am a I'm a
convert now I think I think a lot of the
characters there again it's the deleted
scene stuff because some of Lex Luthor's
motivations are quite confusing and they
just don't seem to have any he's just
sort of there to mess things up a little
bit right he's sort of taking
like a joker stance or he just wants to
watch the world burn he's I'm genuinely
convinced that one of his first words in
the movie are ahoy-hoy so he does like
The Full Monty burns we've got some
questions from Twitter for ya well kinda
asks how would you rank
batfleck in the pantheon of Batman's the
bat hierarchy yeah so my favorite Batman
is Michael Keaton I think it's like like
the Bond thing like you love the Batman
that grew up with so I grew up with Mike
Peyton I would say he's an easy second
yeah I genuinely want his performance
was great I preferred it to bail but I
thought he did a real good job Kevin
Conroy is the best balance Oh trick
question yeah yeah that is that was a
trick question
Raul arias great name says the critics
are being very harsh they are destroying
this movie but fans seem to love it I'm
not sure what fans role is referencing
how would you describe it you think it's
fair that critics are destroying it is
the is the treatment is getting amongst
critics warranted if you come at it as a
film and completely ignore the comic
backstory then you will not enjoy it
because with comics you have that
knowledge of the extended law the
universe that it's set in and you know
that like these fantastical things can
happen if you come on expecting a really
great well put together movie that
completely makes sense and is coherent
throughout sorry sauce I think for DC
fans is always gonna be something in
them Jose Maria Quiros asks is there too
much CGI destroying city all over the
place or is there some actual character
development that isn't cringy yeah
there's a lot of City destroying a lot
of like a like a couple of real big
fights in terms of character development
isn't cringy there's no more goofy Clark
Kent
no more like Smallville farm boy he
yeah which I find quite disturbing
because I grew up on like the adventures
of Lois and Clark so he is a super
po-faced or the whole thing Batman you
expect that Alfred is great I think
Jeremy Owens did a great job as Alfred
he has the kind of dry sardonic wit of
Alfred Lois Lane nothing she did the
best with what she had
final question comes from man we you
kind of discussed it earlier but just
going back to it do you feel does the
movie feel like it's overstuffed with
characters I think if you just kept it
like an adaptation of the DA Knight
Returns it would have been great
obviously I understand they have to
plant seeds for the Justice League it's
it's a shame because there's a lot like
a lot going for this movie and then it's
just it's too many cooks I think I'm
sorry to hear that it's not great but as
long as a Batman hits the right knows
that I'm cool with that so as I
mentioned I'm gonna doing a spoiler cast
with Luke Westaway if you've got any
more questions that can veer into
spoiler territory let me know because
we're gonna be ripping through them and
for more on Batman vs Superman make sure
you keep your eyes peeled to Gamescom